tagashi has just dropped a nen bombshell
I know that often these titles can be
admittedly a bit exaggerated but if
there was ever a time to use the word
bombshell it is right now tagashi has
completely changed how we understand nen
he's revealed previously unknown
characters affinities he's changed the
Affinity of some from previously
established material and he has
introduced an entirely new category of
Nets so we've got a lot to cover and
let's start with our Brand New Concept
characters in Hunter Hunter are no
longer necessarily subject to a single
net Affinity instead they can now be
assigned dual affinities so for example
on the ninring a character no longer
needs to be a natural enhancer or
transmuter and instead they can be
plonked smack bang in the middle of that
their ring thus becoming either an
enhanced transmuter or a transmuter
enhancer and Togashi went on to reveal
that one very key protagonist is
actually a dual Affinity user and that
would be best boy kilua previously
thought of as a pure transmuter he is
now a transmuter enhancer which makes
more sense in the company who sells
kilowatt his beloved choco robocandy in
retrospect I think it really does fit
because kilima has never really dipped
into his neighboring Affinity of
conjuration and being half enhancer
that's understandable because using his
aura that way would be very inefficient
especially since he is still for all
intents and purposes a rookie nen user
just to fly like this I often see a
misconception that kilowatt conjured his
yo-yo weapons but those were actually
given to him by miliki who has a big nen
Revelation himself that we will get into
shortly and by the way the reason why we
know all of this is because Togashi
wrote slash drew a memo detailing all of
these characters and where they sit on
the nen ring as part of his exhibition
in Japan so this isn't like sketchy
unreliable Data Book knowledge no this
comes straight from the mouth and or
hand of the dude himself also this video
is sponsored by zenmarket an amazing
Japanese proxy shopping service based in
Osaka Japan Zen Market allows you to buy
from over 10 000 Japanese stores
including Amazon Yahoo Japan Rakuten
Pokemon centers as well as P Bandai
pop-up raid army army and more all chock
full of Glorious Hunter Hunter Jujutsu
kaisen and JoJo merchandise some of
which are items that are released early
or in many cases only sold in Japan and
the fact that they don't ship overseas
has always been the bane of my existence
but Zen Market solves all of those
problems it's a dream come true for me
and a nightmare come true for my bank
account plus then Market has recently
added the online flea market rahma
hosted by one of the largest shopping
sites in Japan trusted and used by
Japanese people daily you can click my
link in the description to shop through
the New World review landing page
containing all sorts of hunt hunt
goodness with free account registration
and a gift of 300 Yen for new members
essentially waiving the service fee of
your first item so do that thing but for
now it's back to you me and clarify even
characters with dual Affinity still have
one innate natural Affinity which is
determined by the water divination test
however in terms of practicality they
can access either of the Dual affinities
with equal ease now to get back to said
dual affinities Marchi is another
recently revealed transmuter enhancer
again perfect because what she does is
transmute Aura into string and then make
the string like really strong with a
layer of enhancement on top of it we
also have some very straightforward
characters like Franklin who is now a
dual emitter enhancer so basically
taking the simple aspects of Both Worlds
firing super powered Aura bullets but
things get much more interesting on the
lower half of the nenring kite and
subhane classically thought of aspio
chondras are now conjurer transmuters
which I think makes so much more sense
of sabani's abilities in particular
because right as high as just such a
wacky and unique ability perfectly
fusing conjuration and transmutation to
morph and fuel her body and with this
new information we actually have a bit
of a pattern emerging whereby dual
wielders of conjuration and
transmutation have a particular ability
or have access to a particular specialty
with greater ease Hanzo for example is
the other way around he is a
transmutochondra both of which in use to
us previously his Affinity was
completely hidden but he can create an
astral projected clone of himself so
again this Fusion of transmutation and
conjuration appears to lend itself to
nen users being able to naturally excel
at powers that involve their own living
matter whereas standard condorous Focus
mainly on new objects or beings and
standard transmuters on Raw substances
whereas this dual Affinity is
appropriately combining both like in
conjure living matter and then I can
transmute the fuel it needs to function
and even biscuit fits into this function
she is stated by togashi's memo to be a
pure transmuter so it took quite a bit
of struggling and it certainly didn't
come naturally but with a strong enough
desire she subconsciously dipped into
this phenomenon to transform her own
body now on the other side of the ring
is Melody who is now an emitter
manipulator which explains her insane
proficiency with both being able to
admit Aura via music and manipulate the
feelings of the listeners but here is
why things get very interesting because
we're inching up against specialization
and we currently only have one dual
specialist that is obviously karapika
who is a condra specialist very
predictable but I do find it interesting
that he doesn't swap pure affinities and
instead he's always just been in the
dead center of both so naturally he can
access both a lot easier than most if
well if any in fact this probably
explains why some net users do go on to
become Specialists later in life because
they already had a natural bias towards
that section once you've dipped into
specialization on this no going back
is what you are now the only dual
Affinity we have no example of as of yet
is a manipulator specialist and the
closest thing we have is actually
milliki who is the only character
revealed so far to lean specialist
alright there's a new word leaning what
does leaning mean well in addition to 50
50 dual affinities Togashi has made the
World of Fun to Hunter infinitely more
nuanced or infinitely more complicated
in the depends how you feel about it but
instead of a 50 50 split nen users can
now have any ratio Split milliki For
example only leans very slightly towards
specialist so he's more like 95
manipulator and five percent specialist
meanwhile a character like Leorio sits
about here on an end ring being
approximately 60 admitter and 40
enhancer with leoria I think that's
perfect because he does possess a lot of
the very typical enhancer qualities you
know Simplicity and straightforwardness
which I should say is criteria from
hisokus personality test however that
personality test at this point might
actually be more accurate than water
divination to assign affinities because
it's actually starting to break down
that nuance better than the liquid can
but this Affinity laning does get quite
painfully precise apparently in certain
places like say ikalgo who according to
the diagram is like 98 enhancer and 2
percent emitter which is one of those
things where I'm just like why is it why
is that so specific what was tagashi
thinking is there some like in-world
logic to his abilities that means he
needs that slight bias or is this just a
way of adding flavor and diversity to
the system here's the thing though for
someone like you cargo that two percent
emission lean is probably meaningless
however at the very top levels of Nan
even a minor lean could make all the
difference because across large
quantities of aura that two percent is
going to add up let's say you have two
equally matched enhancers one is pure
100 enhancer and the other is 98 and
both of whom also rely on splashing into
their neighbor of a mission in a battle
of attrition the enhancer who has that
two percent bias towards mission is
going to be spending less Aura than
their opponent it's a minor amount but
it elevates that probability of Victory
from Razer thin to well and truly in
favor of the enhancer who leans even
slightly into a mission that is a very
specific situation but I think that's in
keeping because tagashi loves his very
specific numeric based situations and I
love that Togashi is always thinking in
this way the world of nen is always
deepening and expanding even this far on
every new layer brings a whole new
degree of complexity but also in a
Perfectly Natural and non-contradictory
way when a lot of authors make changes
to their power system it often leads to
some continuity issues because the rules
they originally set were so stringent
but I think that togashi's great
Advantage was making the original nen
system just like so vague that he had a
lot of room to sculpt and refine it over
the course of hunt Hunter that's right
I'm saying that Togashi basically
improvised his way into creating the
perfect power system although to be
honest sometimes nen doesn't even feel
like a magic system stuff like this
almost painted as more of a fictional
science consistently making new
discoveries and revolutionizing what we
know about how the world functions
speaking of how the world functions net
leanings can actually change if
characters devote more time to one
Affinity then over over time it sort of
moves them along on the ring sort of
like gaining experience I suppose so net
leanings are not a fixed thing that
you're just born with but it's not all
about new affinities tagashi with this
memo has actually revolutionized a lot
of what we know in regards to Pure
affinities as well Isaac National is our
prime example here because after years
and years and years of unreliable
information he is finally confirmed to
be a pure enhancer this is big
especially for people like me who talk
about him on the internet because
previously all we had to go on was the
databot classification which is being
known to not be so great before and
actually it is wrong again because
tagashi has contradicted it as we'll
find out soon but not in the case of
natural so Nero is an enhancer and what
this does is very much solidify his
legacy as one of the world's greatest
nen users because as a pure enhancer his
100 type guanine borisatva is rooted in
his two most unfriendly affinities being
conjuration and manipulation it conjures
the statue of guanyin and then he
manipulates it with prayer the whole
prayer things are pretty harsh
restriction which is why it's so damn
effective but it's insane to think that
the flagship ability of Isaac netro is
composed of his two most inefficient
affinities you know thinking about it
being a pure enhancer is probably one of
the best case scenarios because it's the
only pure Affinity that gives you the
opportunity to conveniently Splash into
all of the other affinities I mean
except the specialization but there so
it gives you this whole world of
diversity but then again almost no pure
enhancer ever takes advantage of that
they're mostly like whoa I punch strong
now but also we do have some big
enhancement news because something very
surprising is that tagashi has revealed
that komugi is actually a pure enhancer
previously she was thought to be a
specialist due to the very
hyper-specific nunability of being like
really really good at goongi and I
suppose her enhancement might be more
abstract in nature like enhancing her
mind to the point where it functions at
higher capacities but only in regards to
gungi but I do love the idea that the
only person in this world capable of
defeating marowam was not only a frail
blind child but on top of that had the
most basic net Affinity possible and it
just makes the comedy character that
much more amazing to me but also having
brought him up merom that that is
probably the biggest shock in this
entire memo a lot of people who watch
and read Hunter Hunter tend to assume
that marowen was an enhancer and I don't
blame them for that because he always
tends to use his Aura in very basic
enhancer style ways like I said before
punch hard now however in two separate
sources being the hunt hunt Omnibus
treasure and the hunter hunter battle
collection he was defined as a
specialist which looked back then I'm
not going to argue with because if
anyone deserves to be a specialist this
is definitely the ant king but Togashi
dropped a whole Poor Man's rose on this
one because according to the memo
marowam is a pure emitter you heard
correct the most remarkable nen user in
all of Hunter Hunter has been given the
most traditionally unremarkable category
and I do feel the need to apologize
because I always meme on a mission and
emitters you know being the Affinity
that Togashi forgot but look now that
they have the ant king it is it's pretty
damn impossible to make fun of them
which is a shame because I enjoyed that
however I should say that when it comes
to marowam his Affinity is an eye on
meaningless at his level he would still
be able to use each area minus
specialization to a much higher degree
than almost any living being which
tagashi designates because we also have
a new system of identifying just how
well one has mastered their Affinity
with four nen rating levels being great
excellent genius and at the very tippy
top ultimate which does cause some very
interesting actions which I think will
cause people to argue on the internet
Silva and xenozoldik for example Silva
is rated as a genius level transmuter
while Xeno has achieved the rank of
ultimate meanwhile alaka is the only
ultimate specialist which I imagine is
referring to nanaker as well which also
very casually serves as the first time
we've had confirmation that alaka slash
nanika and then uses it all let alone
Specialists I mean given the world that
we're reading about I always assumed
that it was nen but it's just nice to
have that clarification and gone very
briefly became an ultimate ranked
enhancer when he transformed into his
adult form prior to that he was a great
enhancer so he literally went from the
very bottom to the very top and now he
is simply designated as nen lost but
this is wild because probably the most
unexpected of nen ratings comes from
this character who I think most people
probably just forgot about but it's up
in Ghana the Nan Exorcist from Greed
Island who for whatever reason is stated
to be an ultimate ranked conjurer now at
this point I should say this doesn't
mean that up and Gunner is on the same
level as his other ultimate peers what
it actually means is that he has reached
the attainable Apex of his particular
ability and good on him which makes the
rest of this list very intriguing for
example moral who I often praise as one
of the best known users in the series
only has a ranking of great with his
ability I think it's as a result of
moral needing to use his most unfriendly
Affinity transmutation as a key element
of deep purple and because of that the
ability may be forever stifled in the
great rating category because moral just
doesn't have the efficiency to produce
it in a more efficient way and work up
the ranks to excellent genius and maybe
ultimate I guess think of Deep Purple as
a budget Swiss army knife compared to
like a beautifully forged Katana one of
them is Peak quality and will always be
better at 1 particular job which is all
of the cutting but the other despite its
lack of quality will always just be more
generally useful that's deep purple it
was also highlighted that dual Affinity
users will generally have a harder time
reaching the ultimate rating because
they generally need to master two
affinities as opposed to just one and
also this memo does leave us with
certain questions such as very
deliberately singling out Jing as
someone who is still unknown but also
the characters listed aren't anywhere
close to the full cast of Hunter Hunter
there are no Dark Continent no
succession War characters on the chart
so like no Beyond natural and in fact
none of the zodiacs listed there either
which sadly means no new paristan
information but this memo is still
absolutely insane and will completely
redefine then discussion going forward
and full credit to voracious cake on the
hunt and subreddit for providing these
much needed translations